- It's like we called each other
and I was like, you wear
your black and white.
I'm just saying, we look like
we're about to do a show,
or break out into a song.
- Well, you called me last night.
- I did.
- And said make sure you wear
black and white, didn't you.
- I was the person in your
bushes, like outside your house.
It wasn't weird.
Well, do you still,
I heard that you kick
balls into your crowd.
I've never had the pleasure
of seeing your full show,
which I'm super jealous about right now,
but I hear that you kick
balls in your crowd.
Do you kick people? I love this.
(Kelly & Rod laugh)
Because now I really want to
go just to play dodge ball.
- Come up to Vegas. I'll take
you up on my private plane.
- Okay! I've been kissed.
There's a private plane.
I love our relationship.
(Kelly laughs)
- No. I used to kick the
footballs out in the crowd,
I've been doing it since
I was with the Faces.
Remember the Faces? A
bit before your time.
(audience applauds)
- That's amazing though, that's fun.
Did they all catch them and keep them?
Or do they keep?
- Well that's the trouble
see people catch them
and they're all signed,
I signed every one.
- So they're not gonna?
- 60. Yeah but they get,
they get stolen by people.
- Oh!
- You know, the people wait outside.
So usually you stick them
up your tummy, like that.
And then cause somebody
else would come and nick it.
So it has been fights and everything.
- Oh my God!
- So I had to stop it.
- Oh, that's a bummer.
- Yeah.
- Look how people just ruin cool things.
- [Rod] Yeah.
- That sucks.
I heard this about your wife
and I think this is amazing.
So your wife Penny, she had
a change of vocation. Right?
She, she does a different job now. Right?
(Rod laughs)
- She is a policeman now. Yeah.
Police woman.
- That's amazing!
- Yeah.
- Like, she just decided
she was going to do it?
That's amazing.
- Yeah.
She does one day a week
and she wanted to do it
because, you know, for the obvious reasons
give something back to society.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But she said, it's touched my heart.
She said, I love London and
I want to protect it, so...
- You have such a great wife.
- [Rod] Yeah.
- Wow.
I just thought it was such
a cool thing to do in life.
Like and later.
Like you were just like,
yeah I'm going to do this,
and I think that's amazing.
- Yeah.
- Imagine if we all did
that to take care of our,
and then you've got to
see through their eyes,
everybody taking care of us,
you don't see the sacrifice
and how hard it is.
- Yeah.
- I think it's a beautiful thing.
- She, she gets recognized.
- Yeah.
- You know.
- But that's probably harder.
- Oi! Penny how's Rod?
All right! Hey, hey!
(Kelly laughs)
- Well, maybe she stops a
lot of crime from happening,
so that's awesome.